الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك
اللواء الدويري هذا الحديث الروسي عن
مواصله استعدادات لنشر اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه على اراضي بيلاروسيا ما مدى
خطورته كيف يمكن قراءته وفي اي سياق يمكن
وضعه
يعني انا اضع في سياق محدد وهذا السياق هو
التشبه
بالمقاربه الامريكيه المقاربه الامريكيه
واضحه وثابته منذ معاهده ستارت يوجد 150
قنبله نوويه تكتيكيه منتشره في العديد من
الدول الاوروبيه في المانيا في هولندا في
بلجيكا في ايطاليا وفي تركيا
وحتى ابعد من ذلك الان الخبر يقول او
التصريحات الروسيه انها سترسل عشره طائرات
قادره سيتم بناء مستودعات لكن المقاربه
الروسيه الامريكيه تقريبا تلتقي في نقطه
واحده ان هذه الاسلحه وهذه المستودعات
والتحكم بها والوصول الى في الجانب الارب
الامريكي يقتصر بالمطلق على الجانب الام
وان كانت في قواعد المانيه وغير ذلك كذلك
في بيلاروسيا لن يصل الجندي البيلاروسي
الى هذه المستودعات ستبقى ضمن السيطره
المطلقه
الكامله الروسيه
تلك المناورات التي تجريها بيلاروسيا
للدفاع الجوي بالتزامن مع هذا الاعلان
الروسي عن نشره تلك الاسلحه النوويه
المقصود به يعني هي ليست اكثر من رسائل
بان بيلاروسيا تقف بالمطلق في الجانب
الروسي وتعتبر نفسها مهدده واذا روسيا
خسرت الحرب في اوكرانيا فالخساره
ستطالب بلا روسيا ستطال روسيا البيضاء
بسبب التكامل المطلق ما بين الدولتين لهذا
السبب هي تجري هذه المناورات على انها
مستعده لان هناك ايماءات ان حلف يتوسع
واذا ربح الحرب في اوكرانيا قد تنتقل
شراره الحرب الى روسيا
وبلاروسيا الان هي مستعده لديها اسلحه
نوويه وان كانت خارج سيطرتها التقنيه
الحقيقيه ولديها الان منظومات صواريخ دفاع
جوي متطوره قد تتعامل مع التفوق الغربي في
الطائرات المقاتله في التزامن يعني يستمر
الغرب بتزويد اوكرانيا بتلك الاسلحه
المتطوره لكن مع ذلك الكريم لاني يقرر او
يعلنوا بان لا تغيير في الخطط العسكريه
لكن جميع وكافه
الخيارات مطروحه امامها عن ماذا يتحدث
الكرملين برايه كيف يمكن ترجمه هذا
التصحيح هو يتحدث عن بعدين يتحدث عن البعد
النووي في اطاريه التكتيكي
وفي الثالوث الاستراتيجي ان العقيده
النوويه الروسيه واضحه ومتى استخدام
السلاح النووي التكتيكي والاستراتيجي كذلك
الظروف التي تسمح باستخدامه استلالا
استنادا الى العقيده معروفه وفيما يتعلق
بالمعارك الميدانيه المعارك الميدانيه
الهدف الروسي واضح استعاده السيطره على
اقليم دمبس بالمطلق سبعه بالميه من لوغانس
وحوالي خمسين بالميه من دون
اربعين الى 45% من جبالوجيا وبحدود الاقل
من 40% من خرسون هذه المناطق هي في
الاقاليم التي تم ضمها وتم اعتبارها جزءا
من روسيا وهي الان تسعى لاستعاده السيطره
على ما فقدته او ما لم تستطيع الوصول اليه
وبالتالي المقاربه الميدانيه ثابته اشكرك
من عمل
العسكري والاستراتيجي